à Montréal de son bureau avec vue sur la
place des Festivals le nouveau ministre
de la Culture réfléchit à l'avenir de la
culture québécoise enfin que ça nous
rappelle les défis qu'on a le museau
d'art contemporain en bas ça me rappelle
toujours donc les chantiers qu'on a
devant je Matthieu Lacombe déclare sous
serment 4 mois après son assermentation
Mathieu Lacombe ancien journaliste
devenu ministre de la culture sans le
besoin d'aider les artistes à se relever
de la pandémie en continuant de les
financer adéquatement on laissera pas
tomber le monde culturel on laissera pas
tomber nos créateurs nos créatrices nos
entreprises culturelles on sera encore
au rendez-vous je peux pas être plus
clair que ça moi c'est le message que
j'ai envie de leur envoyer un montant je
peux pas m'avancer sur le montant
évidemment parce que le budget il est en
cours de rédaction le grand défi de son
mandat sera aussi d'intéresser les
jeunes à la culture québécoise à une
époque où les plateformes des côtes en
continu ne privilégie pas nécessairement
le contenu d'ici il faut rejoindre les
jeunes où ils sont c'est-à-dire dans le
monde numérique et quand je dis il faut
se faire une première place dans le
monde numérique on parlait de séance
tantôt mais faut leur proposer du
contenu à ces jeunes qui sont sur les
plateformes notamment faut leur proposer
du contenu québécois donc il faut en
produire d'abord il n'y a jamais eu
autant de livres et de disques sur le
marché québécois mais paradoxalement ils
ne sont pas toujours bien mis en valeur
le ministre veut développer le numérique
mais surtout la mise en marché des
produits culturels c'est très
contradictoire comme comme écosystème
vous avez raison de dire il y a une
effervescence là incroyable et on se le
fait dire est-ce que ce qu'on fait est
trop éparpillé est-ce qu'on devrait pas
se concentrer qu'on parle d'intelligence
d'affaires sur un deux trois projets
précis où on sera capable de mettre en
commun nos données puis ensuite de ça de
prendre des décisions basées sur ces
données là on ne peut pas améliorer ce
qu'on mesure pas à chaque fois
pour se perdre de famille de 34 ans il y
a une certaine urgence d'agir l'enjeu de
la langue il est primordial
il faut tout faire pour qu'on continue
par les français au Québec dans 100 ans
quand on regarde les chiffres là depuis
le début des années 2000 c'est alarmant
ça a pas bougé pendant 100 ans depuis le
début des années 2000 quand je suis
libre mais est-ce que ces paroles se
traduiront par des gestes concrets dans
le prochain budget provincial la réponse
le 21 mars prochain ici oui Philippe
Montréal